好,
這邊歡迎收聽早晨財經因素解讀,
現在是臺北時間2026年9月30號禮拜三,
早上8點35分,
大家早安,
我是劉廷浩,
每天早上開拍前半小時,
我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經,
新聞時事變化。
旅館的網路並不是特別好,
所以剛才搞了一下,
昨天有網友說稍微有一聲很大聲,
因為桌子不大了,
剛才不小心,
有時候會不小心頂到一下,
那有時候東西會掉下來,
所以大家請包涵。
那也很神奇
這邊網絡還不錯
現在看起來網絡又不是特別好
所以大家請見諒
那我們今天會主要跟投資朋友分享
利率持續維持在高檔
那美國股市會如何來做一些反應
30年期美債之類率
我們都很清楚知道
自從10年期最近創高以後
30年期本來是在高位盤旋
昨天又創高了
來到5.62%
這是2002年6月份以來的新高
也壓抑住了目前的股票市場表現
10年期美債殖利率在昨天也碰到了5.29%
快要到5.3了
這是07年6月份以來的新高
30年級殖利率現在維持在高檔以後
代表的是
不管是短天期長天期
所有發債成本都在快速的往上衝
那這個時候就要回過頭說
除了美國國債上個月突破了40兆美元
財政赤字以及發債壓力以外
之前我們提到的通膨要求
市場更高的風險貼水
都影響到了長天期美債的承接意願
那現在唯一的好事就是
過去我們提到
債券市場很明顯已經有點恐慌了
可是美國股市還撐得住
十年期美債值略略的快速飆升
它直接導致了衡量美債波動率
我們把它理解成
美債的恐慌指數
Move指數
在短短兩個交易日內快速的爆衝
所以債券市場恐不恐慌
從避險情緒來看
其實是非常非常恐慌的
可是如果我們以VIX來做觀察
就會發現其實表現還好
現在VIX出現了比較巨大的落差
那就是標普白指數
幾乎沒有非常明顯的避險情緒正在發酵
其實也就說明著
現在市場上把高殖利率
還不能夠完全解讀成通膨全面失控
我們可以把它解讀成
經濟好像比想象中強很多
今年十年期美債殖利率
上升幾乎全部都來自於實質殖利率的提高
那麼通膨預期變化反而是有限的
也就說明著
其實只要經濟和企業的獲利持續成長
大型企業還是有能力去消化比較高的利率
不過這主要是標普白指數層面的現象
如果你說中小型股
市場上利率最為敏感的小型股
它就有很明顯的沉壓形象
羅素2000最近的疲弱就是一個例子
那真正的風險其實就在於
如果實質殖利率長時間維持在高檔
債市的恐慌
遲早有一天會傳導到股票市場
那我們現在就看
能不能按在現在的利率水準
不要讓恐慌持續的往下來做蔓延
現在美國股市從相關性跟美債
來做一些追蹤
會發現其實也算是到了歷史低點
剛才提到
各股之間的聯動性
其實也降得非常低
標普500成分股
在過去6個月的實際相關係數
大概降到了5.2%
這應該是2011年
有資料以來的最低記錄
很有可能也是歷史低點
換句話說
就算現在有股票在跌
它也不是一起漲跌
它是不同產業
不同公司各走各的
雖然個股的波動不小
不過整體指數波動
大家也觀察出來了
從下半年以後
其實沒有什麼太大波動
你就躺著在那邊
你就穩穩的領襲
好像也沒有什麼太大影響
下半年的量縮
其實也是在反映這樣的事情
就是虧也虧不了多少
漲也漲不了多少
可是從個股來看
可能體感就會非常顯著的惡化
所以我們基本上可以作為第一層斷定
就是雖然市場上有通膨害怕的因子
可是這一輪的殖利率爆衝
其實沒有那麼直接性的相關
因為通膨從3月4月
我們大概整條路線就已經預估好了
今年的明目殖利率累計上漲
大概是97個基點
那通膨預期
大概也不過十個基點
大部分都來自於實質值利率的上升
就是錢本身變貴了
是目前利率預期上升的主要原因
那當然它背後的原因
就是AI的搶錢潮
AI的投資潮所帶動的效果
那當然再回過頭說
標普500內部所出現的罕見分裂
昨天我們提到
大概有接近一半的成分股跟大盤
是處於反向波動的
以前是標普500指數上漲
也不能說成分股都一定要跟著漲
但是現在是很多標普白指數的
大型科技股在上漲
結果部分科技股反而在反向下跌
其實就來自於少數的巨型企業
目前推動非常明顯的分化跡象
那就說明著跟臺灣市場一樣
很多股票可能年底臺灣股市
還是能夠上5萬點
可是它只要稍微拉一下臺積點
拉一下聯發科就過了
但對於5、6月份
那一輪套牢的個股
你不要講今年了
搞不好明年都無法解套
這個就是目前
在個股指數分化所出現的現象
有些人會很擔心
這種現象拿來跟過往歷史來做對照
會呈現什麼樣的效果
我們以費辦來看
費辦大概距離6月份的高點
大概還有接近14%左右的距離
30檔成分股當中有10檔
距離52周高點超過30%
所以它是跟臺股的部分
五六月份當時的高基期概念股有點類似
因為很多股票要回漲
其實有很大很長一條路要走
納斯達克100指數
距離歷史高一點不到1%
但成分股占上年限的比例
其實也不到60%
說明指數現在大家都越來越高
可是上漲動能都是集中在少數全資股當中
有些人說這就跟2000年當時有點像了
我們如果做圖片來做細節對照
當時在2000年前後
其實費辦常常一談就給你談個兩成五
談個兩成八
然後每次都沒創高
結果發現整個頭部
在短短的2000年的半年內已經逐步形成
所以很多人說
2000年的網絡泡沫高點過了之後
費辦只要沒有創高
他就一路的接下來要瘋狂的下跌了
到時候熊市可能就是跌50%
60%甚至70%起跳
當然如果細節觀察
好像有點道理
30檔股票當中距離52周高點
平均下跌是25%
現在即便談了這麼多
距離高點比較近的就是少數那幾只
比如說臺積電AD
剩下7.1%
輝達剩下3.9%
超維現在只剩下0.2%
可是很多個股其實跌得非常慘
像格羅方德跌了48%
安生美跌了47%
KLA跌了40%
所以很多人會擔心2000年事件
是否會重新的重演
把標普52周創新高的加速
減去52周創新低的加速
是-23
這代表最近創一年新低的股票
遠遠比創一年新高的股票來得高
這個就是美國股市的真實概況
那我個人的看法是
其他背後的原因還是一樣
因為真的能夠在AI領域站穩腳跟的
其實就是這少數幾隻大型科技股
我們不能夠想象
所有人在AI產業都能夠語入均沾
所以從股價層面來看
現行的確有點類似2000年
可是從股價其他指數來看
其實有些已經率先帶頭做突破了
那AI又集中在少數科技權值股
也不能夠完全把它拿來
跟2000年來做對照
生產力的不同
還有泡沫加速的不同
其實都是如此
那現在我們在AI投資持續帶動底下
另外一個拖動因子的
其實就是美國的核心耐久裁定單
就是我們當然知道
現在AI把大部分的訂單都給吸走了
可是在這次8月份所公佈的耐久財訂單
它至少連續17個月保持在高強度成長
年增幅大概是11.1%
這個是2022年第二季以來的最高水準
這說明著
其實就算是AI可能對於市場有部分衝擊
不過它至少讓明目上的數據表現得更好
沒有AI難道現在的經濟就會變得更好嗎
所以這是兩種層面的一個問題
當然它也就隱含著部分個股
的確有顯著弱化的跡象
我們舉一個比較標準的
麥當勞
麥當勞這部分
最近已經跌到接近要疫情等級了
我們看在整個第二季
美國銅電銷售僅僅成長0.8%
七八月甚至稍微下滑
現在股價層面大概已經跌回到
這算是2022年的慘狀了
這種跌幅其實算蠻重的
上方套羅馬亞也非常沉重
主要來自於低收入戶的族群
縮減了外食的支出
迫使麥當勞重新依靠5美元套餐
折扣和數位優惠來刺激客流
另外一方面
現在牛肉價格又很貴
人力價格成本又很高
公司又要降價搶客
又要面對成本壓力
獲利空間就遭受到兩面夾擊
這就是那種AI概念股跟非AI概念股
雙方所形成的衝擊
就連過去認為具有高強度護城河的穿山股
這一輪的價格表現也不是特別好
道瓊最近表現就稍微差了一點
大家可以觀察到
唯一的好處就是
AI至少把整個經濟數據
稱得相當漂亮
漂亮到FOMC聯準會目前的歷史
沒有任何一位成員
認為經濟存在下行空間
我們看這次聯準會官員所公佈
超過400位經濟學博士
提供的研究資源
回顧2012年以來
四次最悲觀和最樂觀的極端時間點
八次案例
每一次股市泡沫破滅
通常都是發生在經濟成長
高強度拉昇的時候
現在問題就來自於
這一次的FOMC
其實也沒有任何一名票委
認為經濟有下行的壓力
要不然早就投給降息票了
所以這就形成了
現在聯總會官員
按照目前的數據
我們不看個體
基本上他也沒有什麼
太多看快的一個壓力
美國股市現在就是如此
幾年之後我們回看2026年
大家可能只記得標普500
站在歷史高檔
覺得這是一段非常漂亮的多頭
但是真正身處其中看到的
可能是美債資利率
它已經突破5%了
再次的波動快速的升高
市場廣度快速惡化
就好像2020年
後來股市又創高了
你說2020年不是新冠疫情嗎
對啊
那怎麼會股市創高了呢
海量貨幣寬鬆
甚至現在很多半導體個股
從高點修正了兩三成
也就是說指數看起來很強
但不代表市場裡面每一個角落都很強
歷史上最有可能的
只是留下一個標普白指數當中的一個點
或者一個線或者一個K棒
但投資人面對的
我們要知道當年度的波動
也許比想象中還要來得大
非凡現在很多個股利高點還有兩三成
市場廣度現在轉負
很有可能完全就是另外一個世界
這讓我想到
因為這兩天我剛好去莫扎特之家
莫扎特是神童
大家應該都知道
那最令人驚奇的是什麼
就是除了他有他的專業以外
他最擅長的其實就是幹話
簡直就是我的偶像
因為莫扎特私底下
其實非常喜歡講那些低俗笑話
我還特別去找了一下
就莫扎特
他我們稱之為莫扎特糞便學
就是後代的研究學者們
得知莫扎特家族那個時代
莫扎特寫的信書
書信都非常的
算是屎尿屁齊發
比如說他在寫給表妹的書信裡頭
就有提到說
祝你安眠
但先在床上拉屎
我要在你鼻子里拉屎
我又想起你的便便了
真是太美妙了
我的屁股像火一樣燃燒
他在寫給父親大人的信當中
他也是這麼對老爸講
他說
喂 混賬大人
舔我的屁股吧
除此之外
還有一連串什麼大便真好吃
舔我屁屁
一系列的衝擊詞彙
那這些書
這些信書後來都被保留下來了
我要講什麼
我自從瞭解他的屎尿屁歷史之後
我才發現
雖然他給人家的形象都是比較優雅天才
古典音樂大師
但私底下其實有非常強烈的屎尿屁的幽默
他寫給家人妻子表面
一定要有那種很粗俗的雙關語
簡直是我的偶像
不是更重要的事情是
他還寫了一首詩曲
一個叫倫唱曲
德文我不會念
執意就是舔我的屁股
那是一首歌
那這類作品
都是在熟人或者朋友聚會當中
拿來做娛樂的
那我要講什麼
我要講的概念就是
我們幾百年後想到莫扎特
留下來的印象
往往都是比較優雅
精緻甚至接近完美的古典音樂
可是如果我們翻開他的私人書信
你會發現完全不同的一面
像美國股市就是如此
幾年之後大家回過頭看2026年
你早就已經忘記每一戰事了
你可能覺得
標普白指數當年就是創下歷史新高
美國股市就是一個漂亮多頭
可是真正在其中看到的人
他是美債殖利率的壓力
市場債券市場的惡化
市場廣度的惡化
很多半導機股的高強度修正
所以我們才講說
每看一個點你都是很痛苦的
長期來看你只會覺得
美國股市就很順的就是三代牛
怕什麼呢
所以長期尺度和短期尺度
大家還是要稍微看清楚
好那麼回過頭說
來看一下路透目前所釋出的
Enthropy的招股數
來看一下市場上當然很清楚知道
要給予AI進一步的起量增長
就要端出更為亮麗的財報
這一次文件顯示
Enthropy正在準備要進軍公開市場
潛在估值大概是2兆美元
這是今年5月公司自己估計
9650億美元的兩倍以上
這說明著市場給他的估值還是很高
2023年它的營收大概是0
2024年是4億美元
到2025年
直接飆升到46億
一年是增加10倍
這也顯示目前Cloud
在AI服務的商業化
正在快速的擴張
不過路透社所取得的數據
大概也接了另外一層面
就是它所需要的資金也很誇張
如果我們細看
Enthropy目前的運算和基礎設施
它的支出2023年是4億美元
2024年來到25億
25年來到73億
短短兩年增加17倍
所以它的營收增加了10倍
可是它的支出增加了17倍
速度遠遠比想象中還要來得快
這也導致Enthropy在2025年的
上面虧損大概是420億美元
看起來就遠遠超過
46億美元的營收了
當然我們這邊需要拆開來看
其中大約是340億美元
其實是會計上的評價損失
因為公司估值大幅上升
通常你可能就要轉換成
它的Entropy的股票融資工具
價值會因此而增加
那也不代表它真的把421全部燒完了
但至少可以看得出來
它的運營核心
本身還是處於一個非常嚴重的虧損階段
這裡說明著
現在AI商業模式
它很快又要上市了
大家都很擔心
它會不會是下一個SpaceX的慘狀
但至少可以看得出來
在大幅拉伸的過程當中
它的營收和它的負債
大概都是接近要以10倍左右的速度增長
這個就是AI目前所處於的態勢
你說如果只看資本支出
你會覺得有點擔心
可是它的營收是10倍
如果每年都能夠以5倍到10倍的速度成長
那這個產業難道沒有投資的吸引力嗎
其實我們從AI的投資熱潮
來看全球債券市場
就可以完全瞭解
這一輪的利率預期上升
基本上不能夠把大部分的因子
都怪給美益戰士
也不能夠完全怪給川普
也許現在沒有每一戰事
也不能說完全一定百分之百
利率預期會快速的鬆綁
可能會稍微比現在低一點
但也許利率預期還是有機會升高的
因為還是要搶錢
AI在今年的搶錢上太明顯了
尤其現在美國美元已經搶的差不多了
Meta預計今年秋季
要進入到歐洲債券市場來籌資
加上有亞馬遜
Alphabet
微軟
甲骨文
這些巨頭陸續進入到發債行列
那背後就是資本支出的需求越來越龐大
我們預估在整個第三季
也有可能進一步拉伸
像亞馬遜在6月份
加拿大他又發行了140億加元的債券
一舉打破之前Google
才創下85億加元的記錄
結果Google又在澳洲
又發了55億澳元的債券
在瑞士他又募得31億的瑞郎
亞馬遜在瑞士也募了28億的瑞郎
英國最近出現了超長天期國債的發行
Google今年發行了55億美元的
應該講說50億5億英鎊的債券
其中有10億英鎊
期限是幾年
100年
現在大家就瘋狂開
反正7%的短天期的利率
已經幾乎是保底了
有的開到8%
有的開到9%
反正現在就市場大搶錢
那就說明著AI的爆發力
對於這些巨頭來說
很明顯一年的產出
一定是高過於10%
他才會這麼勇敢的去借錢
這也導致了一個現象
除了美國市場以外
非美市場目前的債券成購量
或者發行量也非常龐大
加拿大就是我們剛才所提到的
外國借款人現在在加拿大
發行的家園債券
大概是450億加元
去年才160億
那你要知道
2022年到2024年
每年也不到100億加元
這說明著市場上在各地
非美市場瘋狂的發行
已經成為了市場主流需求
不過這也就說明著
市場上現在在AI資料中心的擴張當中
你的本業收入能否證明
你可以吸納這麼多錢就非常重要了
我們繼續來說
像軟銀現在旗下的SB Energy
原本預估在9月要上市
估值超過500億美元
但是因為投資人對於估值和執行的風險
產生疑慮
最後延後了
公司的規劃原本要做資料中心
也相當驚人
但目前沒有任何的資料中心正式運營
為什麼
就是你對於新技之門還抱有疑慮
那軟銀旗下的SB Energy
當然要上市的過程當中
大家會給你大打折扣
軟銀現在發行的債券
幾乎等同於垃圾債了
那個殖利率給你拉高到9% 10%
都沒有人要
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
華爾街開始不願意照單全收
而且這軟銀的公司叫做SB Energy
你說叫對不對
名字不是特別好聽
但重點是來自於
債券和專案的融資市場當中
市場上開始做一一的評價
我們舉幾個例子來說
比如說如果細節來看
像甲骨文
甲骨文目前的AI資料中心
上個禮拜我們有提到
在新墨西哥州
木星
人家是星際資本
它是木星計劃
卡關了
當然它表面上說
是因為供電的問題
是因為許可的問題
所以公司是不可抗力的條款
本來2028年第三季
就要完成了第一階段的工程
現在至少要延後一年
甲骨文在2056年到期的公司在地率
現在已經來到8.16%
創下歷史新高了
CDS價格本來已經創高
覺得很誇張
又創高了
一直降頻
現在甲骨文距離垃圾債
接近只有一級而已
你要知道人類的AEI的算力
最大的需求
結果距離垃圾債
它建的錢所需要的資本
基本上只差一級
所以延後也不代表甲骨文
可以不用付錢
因為木星計劃
它的租約還是有采取比較高度的約束性條款
即便資料中心無法取得足夠的電力
公司還是有承擔租金的義務
大概有20家銀行提供接近180億美元的建設融資
目前賬面損失已經超過20億了
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
整體不管是甲骨文還是Meta
最近發了接近6.5%的擔保債券
某種程度都加深了目前AI債的跌勢
這個就是目前市場上所給予的變化
那你現在如果發展的越快
你的基本面又沒辦法
保持足夠良好的證明
出出的代價來的也越快
所以我們才講說
AI投資的速度有時候越快
需要的晶片
電力資料中心融資就越多
那除非你的本業收入
你的身份證明
可以確保你能夠度過本場為期
或者能夠在AI競賽當中
完美的活下來
要不然現在對於這些企業來說
我覺得也不見得是
發越多債越快越好了
因為已經過了那個時間了
我除了去莫扎特之家以外
最近也有去貝多芬之家
都在維也納市東心
然後去看貝多芬
斷斷續續住了八年的地方
有獻給愛麗絲和費德里奧
然後第五號第六號交響區
也在這一帶創作發展
貝多芬就說過一句話
貝多芬說手指有多快
分貝就有多高
就是你看到AI市場
現在比的就是速度
就是模型要更快
晶片要更快
資料中心要更快
沒有
那個是今年上半年以前
到下半年以後
你越快的從市場資本的評價來看
反而有可能遭受到資本市場的狙擊
所以我們才講說
現在美國股市
你不能夠說完全就是處於極端泡沫
市場上充滿著極度的不理性
因為當前來看
每一輪的產品
市場看起來都會以非常刁鑽的角度
來做思維
你像Meta
最近所推出的新產品
它也不見得能夠使得
股價上能夠有效推升
因為之前已經漲很多了
我們看在各大七巨頭層面
所推出的好消息
不管是股票的回購
很多時候都是單日行情
Meta的部分
我們剛才知道
在可擔保
或者說相關科轉債的發行量當中
利率不斷的做提升以外
Meta現在也把過去
看似分開的三條產品線
嘗試的去整合起來
就是AI的大模型代理還有智慧眼鏡
當然還有之前的元宇宙
祖克博也顯示說
最新的AI代理MUSE推出之後反應強勁
上線兩週用戶就已經達到數百萬
接下來還要直接整合到Meta
和Lapoon合作的智慧眼鏡
所以這個時候就要回過頭來看
因為MUSE當時推出以後
的確反應非常不錯
隨時可以呼叫個人的AI代理
但如果股價上
沒辦法一路的往上做推升
就說明著市場還是相信
其他巨頭很快就可以推出相對性的產品
所以AI的競爭看起來是越來越激烈了
最近我們也知道
超微才宣佈以全股票交易
收購了82億美元的李飛飛的World Labs
就預估今年年底就會完成
世界模型最重要的就是打造真正的AGI世界
現在World Labs已經可以利用少數的圖片
來建立一些三維環境
未來能夠進一步應用在機器人
工廠的模組或者科學研究等等
大家都是磨刀霍霍
輝達的部分也把AI晶片變成金融資產
除了之前的5000億美元的擴張計劃以外
現在開始找保險業進來了
我們到這一輪
日穆基金也搶了一筆錢
債券市場搶了一筆錢
IPO搶了一筆錢
輝達現在正在跟美國的大型保險公司
正在討論新的融資模式
就希望把人工智慧晶片
從單純的科技產品
變成可以抵押可以放款
甚至投保的可投資資產
最理想的構想就是
銀行把錢借給規模比較小的
新興雲端業者
然後以輝達的晶片作為抵押品
如果業者倒閉
晶片二手出售的價格
不足以償還貸款
那就由保險機制承擔部分的損失
這麼多的目的
輝達就是希望
如果沒有亞馬遜
沒有Google
沒有這些科技巨頭
我也希望小的雲端公司
也能夠取得大量的資金
來購買輝達的晶片
輝達希望可以幫助這些中小型企業
能夠向外走出去
這個就是目前輝達所表現的態度
那我講一下我個人看法
我個人的看法是
其實按照Enthropy目前的營收成長
你已經大概可以看得出來
科技巨頭的訂單
其實差不多已經能夠足以去支撐
持續性的投資了
其實從AI的投資估值來看
我們過去提到
AI預估本益比的中位數
今年4月還有32倍
現在只剩下22倍了
它的股價也沒有跌多少
可是本益比已經下滑了
說明獲利上升幅度非常快
第二件事情
就是像是亞馬遜
微軟或者Google
三大雲端巨頭
目前手上的合約積壓訂單
就已經來到1.69兆美元了
這代表的事情是
其實有非常多的訂單
之所以還無法快速的有效反映
在營收或者獲利
是因為資料中心沒蓋完
根本就不是沒有訂單的問題
因為沒蓋完
沒敗完沒辦法算力做出租
所以這是我們看到的真實效果
那某種程度而言
我們看到這種環境
第一對於消費者是有利的
因為大家還在降低自己的token價格
第二模型還在持續的進步
第三現在市場上最擔心的就是這件事情
有好有壞
好處就是揮達
想要嘗試走出那種非正規方式
來確保小型的AI公司也能夠獲得資金
那往壞處來看
那就是整個系統性的金融壓力
它會持續的膨脹
如果AI最後發現
它只是一個假殼子
它無法成真
那麼當然就是一場泡沫
可是當AI如果不再只是科技業的故事
它開始一路滲透到每個人的工作
企業的創業
現在銀行的融資
到股市的估值
債券市場也被AI給搶光了
主權基金
退休基金
大家都開始把錢陸續的搶光之後
AI的成功
它如果能夠帶來生產力革命
就是全體人類福祉的提升
可是現在重要的是什麼
現在重要的事情就是
不管它成功或者失敗
因為你的退休基金
主權基金
企業的創業
IPO
銀行融資
股市的估值
債券市場
全部都跟AI綁在一塊了
最後就連你可能最不看好它的人
你都不得不希望這場實驗
最後能夠成功
它失敗了
它影響的不是隻有投AI股票的人
在世退休基金全部都會出問題
因為大家最後已經上癮了
這個就是我們看到最終AI的終局
大家以前聽過阿拉丁神燈的故事
不知道有沒有聽過尼古丁神燈的故事
之前講說一個客幫的傢伙在海邊散步
突然撿到一盞神燈
他擦了兩下
燈神就冒出來
你有三個願望
男生很開心
太爽了吧
第一個願望陪我抽一根
燈神認了一下
兩個人就一起吹著海風抽完
過了一會
男的又把燈神給叫過來
第二個願望
你再陪我抽一根吧
燈神想說又來
那還是坐下來陪他
兩個人就越抽越忙
開始聊宇宙
聊人生
還有海浪
那不知道
到底人生意義在哪裡
聊了很多這樣子
那傍晚
男人第三次叫燈神出來
那燈神說第三個願望
再陪我抽一根吧
燈神嘆了口氣
行吧
兩個人一路抽
抽到晚上
開始夕陽
看星星
半夜12點多
燈神就一路迷濛的
從神燈裡面爬了出來
問那個男的
第四個願望是什麼
這就是尼古丁神燈的故事
會上癮的
所以我們講說
AI如果成功
它可能帶來生產力革命
但如果最後證明
投入遠遠超過回報
衝擊的
它就不會是單純幾隻AI的股價
它會傳導到
整個市場的企業獲利
信用市場
還有銀行的資產
政府基金和一般人的退休賬戶
某種程度上來說
AI本來是一場科技公司的豪賭
現在沒有
現在變成了全球共同壓住的
經濟實驗艙
甚至連最後不看好他的人
你也必須確保他能夠成功
因為他影響的範圍越來越龐大了
這就是我們不得不所採取的方向
好就零三分
我們後續再把整個臺灣市場
或者在產業分論的部分
來跟投資朋友做一系列的梳理
今天主要跟投資朋友分為幾個方向看
第一個是錢變貴了
美債資利率的暴衝
但是美股還在成內部的分化
第二是錢去哪裡呢
當然AI的資本支出吸走了全球的資金
第三個階段
到底本輪的AI會產生什麼樣的效果呢
它產生的效果就是
所有人都被AI經濟綁在一塊了
你只能夠確保它成功
當然從我們的角度來看
第一這些科技巨頭
短期內似乎無法有做獲利的顯著拉伸
它不是來自於沒有訂單
它是因為算力沒有建完
第二可是你建太快
你的資料中心資本支出還在快速拉伸的
其實某種程度而言
市場必須根據你的基本面來做評價
所以現在借越多的
不一定股價漲越多了
最後一件事情是
市場上都在不斷的推出新模型
真正的把它給物理化
不管是推出中端AI或者物理AI
才是本輪這些科技公司
是否能夠成功的重要關鍵
也給投資朋友做一些思考
我們看一下臺北股市的表現
來跟投資朋友做一些追蹤
臺股上漲502點
收在48,130點
對我們在直播
因為我們網絡不太好了
但是還是跟大家看一下盤
其實臺股下半年之後
就維持在這樣的一個盤
是很長一段時間了
可是內部分化也是很明顯的
這個就是從長時間來看
臺股今年就是多頭
從個體時間來看
有些人套牢的股票
今年年底都不一定能夠解套
也給投資朋友做一些思考
如果喜歡我們的節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就明天早上半半
早晨